we got here for the man 36 man
um just because uh you know i had to
just talk to my grandmother and
you know and losing her this year um
still tough every day so
you know this is a tremendous honor
um i thank you all you guys man
especially coach um ever since i came
here giving me this opportunity
growing with you guys especially pat
luke been around you guys
you know ever since coming into this
league man so you know this is really
from you guys i just want to say thank
you for you guys and
we welcome you back kia six man of the
year finalists
a couple of clipper teammates montrez
harrell and lou williams
and dennis schroeder of the oklahoma
city thunder uh now this is gonna narrow
the field by one because
clippers head coach doc rivers helped
deliver the news today
i need your help um
see man what we got here we got here
foreign
um just cause uh you know i had to just
talk to my grandmother and
you know um and losing her this year um
it's still tough every day so
you know um this is a tremendous honor
um uh thank you all you guys man
especially coach um ever since i came
here giving me this opportunity
growing with you guys especially pat
luke been around you guys
you know ever since coming into this
league man so you know this is really
from you guys
i just want to say thank you for you
guys
that is a cool moment as montrez harold
joins us
from the bubble in orlando to to have
that kind of a moment
surrounded by your teammates i imagine
is very cool
and also um look we know it's been a
tough time and you referenced it there
when you when you lost your grandmother
and so
in the midst of some dark times this is
a this is kind of a shining moment for
you how do you feel
um i feel good um it's definitely a
huge honor to be here um you know like
you said i've definitely been battling
some tough times and
you know getting through some dark
places with my family but
we've been you know getting through them
praying each day and
just learning how to keep going and keep
being better each day
you know we know my grandmother is a
huge part of our life and
she's still here with us to this day so
you know we just cherish her each day
and
try to get better tres it's draymond
uh congratulations man i'm super happy
for you uh my question is
when we come into this league there's
something that's driving you
pushing you every day i think over the
course of your career that changes
is that same thing that was driving you
when you initially came in which was
undersized
you're they were saying you went under
size four you're actually planning to
fight
is that same thing driving you today or
has that changed for you
um no it still drives me to this day
because
um when i hear all the outside noise of
what i can't do
every day man and you know that's just
what it is noise man i
i fuel and feed off of things like that
and if people haven't really realized
that then
you know hey keep adding fuel to the
fire man i come in this game looking to
just
work and just do everything i can to put
myself in a position to
not only better myself but better my
teammates you know better people that
surround me and
you know my work speaks for itself man i
don't have to go out here and just you
know
yell and do all this man i came in this
league as a person that was
you know not looked at and was not you
know really in the rotation to play
and i worked my tail off you know i
asked to go down to the g league and i
asked her
you know just be around guys to award
that fact that i was going to play man i
just love this game
and you know i'm blessed to be here i'm
blessed that my grandmother
put the ball in my hands and you know
everything that i'm doing
to this day going forward is going to be
the same as it was before
she left me uh well tremendous award
congratulations you know to be one of
the best
if you really let that sink in best
players in the league
at what you do that's a that's a heck of
accomplishment
but secondly that's a tough role i you
know i i
understand guards but being a sixth man
and being a big like how what's the
mental preparation
to get ready as a big
in being a sixth man and then playing
those minutes that's significant
um i don't know if y'all can see my
shirt for the
this man right here this man right here
you know he taught me everything man
he's been in
a numerous amount of roles where he
could have been on the team and started
and
you know factor it and you know ask for
starting
paying and a lot of different arguments
but he comes in and does
what each team asks him to do and that's
be himself
score the basketball man you know go out
there and do the things that lou does
and he does it to the highest caliber
there is man he's won this award
you know three four times i don't know
how many times man i
feed him up here hold this award but you
know i'm blessed to just be around them
and and have that chance to be able to
norm and and grow and just learn how he
did things as a pro man because
you know lou's
accomplishment speaks for himself man a
lot of people don't really
give that a lot of insight and to give
it a lot of you know hype that it
deserves man this is a guy who has his
own signature signature shoe and peak
um you know he's broken numerous records
as coming off the bench and scoring six
minutes of the year
um i mean he's just a tremendous guy to
be around man i'm just honored that i
could actually be around him and just
learn from him
tres this shack i don't have a question
i just want to say i'm so proud of you
i've been fortunate to to be able to win
four championships because of guys that
work hard like you
donna's haslam james posey rick fox big
shot bob so i'm saying congratulations
keep doing what you're doing and good
luck this year brother
uh for sure chat man it means a lot
you're a great mentor to me
we've connected and talked even
throughout playing in the two league
against your son and you know still a
whole communication through social media
today man so it means a lot that he
say that there's nice going we
congratulate you for everybody here in
atlanta nice going
cool and coming up